where does mar vista go to acquire
movies
so we produce um about 20 to 25 feature
films
on our own each year we produce those
primarily from major networks here in
the united states
and we also have major output deals with
global companies like tf1 and france
uh et cetera so it's like we kind of
know our end user very very well so we
are able to put money into films and and
have a home for those
but we also acquire another 25 to 35
movies per year
sometimes more as we're learning for
2015-16
and we look into like a variety of
sources to find those
we get submissions blindly from
producers
we talk to the major agencies who
represent producers who are making films
on spec
we work with producers representatives
we will basically find any source who
has access to new content and go
look the biggest misconception young
filmmakers have is i'm gonna go produce
a movie
spend a lot of money on credit cards or
something else
um and just get it to film festivals and
everything will magically take place
after that
the truth is like it doesn't happen that
way some companies will buy movies from
film festivals
uh there are some film festivals where
movies are going to find
a home but most of the major film
festivals whether it's toronto
can etc those movies are already being
represented
uh they're looking to showcase it for
foreign clients they're looking to
showcase it for
uh rights overseas or or limited rights
in the u.s like they're being
represented though
we talk about focus groups because you
you
were in the mindset of a young tween
girl and i can tell you it sounds
exactly like all of us women when we
were younger we so how did you know all
this how what type of questions are
asked
what's going on at these focus groups
with the male uh
aging you know superhero movie where you
know the young boy wants to look up to
someone older
that's that's more established what's
going on in these
groups uh you mean in our production
offices like when we're discussing
these films or you mean more in a
general sense more in a general sense
where are you getting the information in
terms of what the audience wants how do
you know that they want all this i get
this information
from data a lot of data of what movies
get revenue in and which movies do not
which movies my foreign buyers respond
to and which ones they don't
which movies domestic tv channels pay
attention to
and which ones they pass on and it's
surprising the movies that
cost very little that uh don't
you know have much to really offer
sometimes get really big sizable
price tags from major tv channels here
in the us
and overseas for a writer
to really you know have one of those
opportunities
it's it's not guessing what people want
it's just being true to the story
being true to the characters um and i'm
in writing for the green light does not
talk at all about the craft of
screenwriting that's not my space
my spa you know there's fantastic books
there's numerous college professors who
can speak to that much better than i can
but i can tell you what works i can tell
you what sells
so how to get into the mindset of a
character it's just
being responsive to what you see in the
real world and not
letting the story get ahead of what a
character would do
if anybody has brothers or sisters
if anybody has children just just
you can try to present something to them
like an idea of maybe what you know we
could do as a family or anything else
and you'll just notice they will react
in ways you don't expect them to and
that's what characters should do too
and universal themes always are the only
thing that will keep that all cohesive
so how to get into the mindset of a
coming-of-age
male actor you just have to look at what
the main audience
is like who the main audience is and
what is it that they hope to get
out of the movie we talked about like if
you're going to a grocery store
and you're purchasing a box of cereal
something like that
you're purchasing because you you want
that taste you want that flavor it's
attractive to you you know what you're
getting at the end of the day
um a movie actually follows the same
mindset people want emotional
experiences
and so if the demo is males of this age
or girls of this
age you have to you're not showing you
don't want to hold up a mirror and show
them reality
you want to show them a fan a fantasy of
what could be
uh and a reflection of what they hope it
it looks like on the other side that's
you're giving them you're giving them an
experience
so get into their mindset of not who
they are what do they want to see
giving people what they want is really
the answer right so one step
up from where they already are yeah yeah
you talked before about women and peril
thrillers that you notice most of them
are
upper middle class right that's because
the average audience is middle class
lower middle class
and they fantasize about what that side
of the tracks looks like
young girls identify with the main
protagonist of a tween girl film who's
kind of a little bit awkward a little
bit shy a little bit unsure of herself
because that's how most
tweens feel males and females so they
look up to
those characters who can move past that
by just being themselves
and that's why that genre works really
well the creature features the same deal
the the male comeback action hero it's
the same deal
the male comeback action hero is
fantastic because it's a it's a male
action hero who's given up that
lifestyle
and then gets forced into it and i think
that's as a middle-aged
man you want to kind of have that dream
fantasy scenario
you could be a dolph lundgren going back
in and you know doing some crazy
missions in a foreign country or
something
so per se you never have like a full
focus group where you sit down women
ages
35 to 45 who make this much money
per year and say which of these scenes
resonated with you most
it's never been i've i've never been a
part of that
i think writers can do i think writers
have the best
capability of learning those skill sets
by by taking acting classes or improv
classes and learning how
actors and how other people will see a
script who aren't writers
we have those focus groups internally as
a company by looking at what our clients
want
because a tv channel in the middle east
or in london or
or in japan they know what their
audience wants they know what tween
girls respond to in
tokyo and so they'll tell us
we really like it when films do this and
if enough of those triggers line up
we know we need to start seeing that in
movies as a writer how do you get there
again you can't guess the trends you
can't guess those factors
so just write really true honest tween
girl films
or or coming of age male action films
dog christmas films any of the gold mine
genres spelled out in writing for the
green light just write any of those
in a universal true way um
and you know you'll get the script will
get noticed and your talent will get
noticed
and then you become pegged as a person
that can be communicated with
to write the scripts that these
companies need that's the idea of it
your first couple scripts out of the
gate they're a business card they're
showcasing what you bring to hollywood
that you understand what hollywood needs
and it needs these kinds of films to
function
so once you know that and you present
that and you show consistency that you
can deliver that
when the other side of the table goes
okay you passed the test you seem to
know what we want
this is what we need written can you do
it and that's how it
really kickstarts
you